- I knew that the train
station was somewhere near…
I am an actor, and I have autism.
It's really hard for people
with any disability to get a large role
in a professional theater.
But for the first time in my life,
I'm getting to star in a
major professional production.
(atmospheric music)
- [Actress] Use those words Christopher.
- You said it on September 12th last year
at first break.
My name is Mickey Rowe, and I am playing
Christopher Boone in the Curious Incident
of the Dog in the Night-Time.
(enchanting music)
The Curious Incident of
the Dog in the Night-Time
is about a boy who has autism
and his adventure that
flips his world upside down.
- [Actress] I pulled myself
together and I hit him.
- [Mickey] I am the first autistic actor
to play Christopher Boone,
and I am surprisingly one of the first
autistic actors to play any
autistic character anywhere.
(atmospheric piano music)
I've had to be an actor my whole life
to pass as neurotypical.
So being an actor comes
so naturally to me.
I use scripting in my daily life.
For example, if I went to a coffee shop,
I might say to the barista,
“Hi, can I please have
a medium drip coffee.
“How is your day going today?
“Has it been busy today?”
And then regardless of what they say,
it's been busy or slow, I can then say,
“Oh, well do you like it better
“when it's busy or when it's slow?”
So that way I can kind of script my life,
so I don't have to deal
with social interactions.
Thank you so much,
have a good rest of your day.
No!
- Alright son, you keep it.
- [Mickey] In rehearsal is my happy spot
because I have the lines,
I'm playing a character.
Everyone else is playing a role,
be it another character
in the play or director.
- Alright, we have to stop there
and take five, you guys.
- During five minute
breaks or 10 minute breaks
or lunch breaks, is when
you feel less comfortable.
You don't have a specific role
during that time, which makes it confusing
for someone on the spectrum.
On stage, there's often
bright lights shining on you,
and loud noises that come out of nowhere
as sound cues.
But you've rehearsed all
of these things in advance,
and you know where each sound cue
is happening 'cause it happens in the exact
same place every night.
So it almost feels like you're
in control of those things.
And because you know what to expect,
you're in on the magic.
(enchanting music)
I would have to talk to
other people, though.
From mission control, but we would do that
through a radio link up and a TV monitor,
so it wouldn't be like talking.
It's so rare for any
actor with any disability
to get to play a leading
role in any production,
let alone a professional
traveling production.
I get to show people that
people with disabilities,
we get the job done.
(clapping and cheering)